oh [__] Monday morning 13th of the month
you [__] wanted it you got it
it's a Monday motivation session with
your [__] great uncle uncle Joey here
coming to you [__] fresh ready to
rock on a Monday [__] morning you
understand who's better than you you're
up
you saluted the flag and most
importantly it's Monday morning
[__] uncle Joey coming to your
direct [__] 10:00 to 8:00 in the
morning who's [__] sparking you
understand me uncle Joey is because I
don't give a [__] Jack that's how you
attack a Monday I got [__] juice on tap
three different flavors ready to go dick
Vicky and Vicky Asst coz I don't give a
[__] Jack it's Monday it's your heart
and balls you put them out there and you
don't give a [__] with smoking some [__]
them tremendously percolate Mars oh gee
that your think you're in [__] Mars
um I just saw a Martian drive behind a
[__] skateboard ten minutes ago
number two having for this other place
lately just to supplement just to see
what's out there you know I'm saying you
gotta look and see what's out there with
your choices up this my boys is terrible
they don't they always got something for
me to [__] take me to the next level
there's something greens I've been Torah
where I [__] cryotherapy at Jesus
Christ this is 30 percent [__] this
is something else this will put you in a
different [__] plan oh but I have to
pat down my [__] grandpa monster head
do you know I'm sayin but looking good
feeling good Billy Ray had a great time
in Kansas City I give a shout-out to
Gloria man man put me through a circuit
training on Saturday all you
[__] that coming school and
[__] Kansas City I will be back there
with no doubts the Emperor throwing
[__] heat we got some barbecue I'm
ready to [__] go it's a whole new
week with a whole new set
rules we got a podcast this afternoon we
got a podcast Wednesday I'm at the store
Wednesday night swinging dick and given
our bubble gum but the best thing is I'm
giving you what's on my mind and what's
on my heart on a Monday morning which is
we don't give a [__]
let me explain something to you today I
gotta walk my daughter to kindergarten
this morning why did they come out here
because I'm telling you the same [__]
talk I'm talking out today I'm a look
her in the eye I'm gonna get on one knee
and I'm gonna tell her I love her don't
take [__] from nobody and today's your
[__] day understand me today whatever
happened last week happened last week
last month last year happened last year
today today starts a new [__]
regime in your life you understand me
today Oh disco taint you know why
because two days and today two days on
Wednesdays only thirty years I went in
front of a judge and have [__]
sentenced it was 30 years ago as I felt
the worst I could ever [__] feel in
my life I thought my life was over but
Here I am
where's I [__] wrong listen you're
wrong your life's not over or you gotta
do is grab your [__] balls salute the
flag put it in your mindset that
somebody's gonna suck your dick clay and
move forward and don't look back look
back to remember where you never want to
be again that's what I [__] do I look
back to remember well I don't want to
[__] be but joy which with the
[__] air beetle while you philosopher
junior
I listen I got him oh look at this this
is a [__] understand me who gives a
[__]
understand me hardest day of my fellows
that little girl in the eye and let it
go to a [__] kindergarten you know
I'm gonna be legs around that school
with [__] BB guns and [__]
slingshots I'll get one of those
[__] but anyway I love you
[__] if he came to the shows in
Kansas City who's better than you you
listen I left my soul on that [__]
stage ain't [__] around no more with
you people
I might say some [__] on life but but
don't give a [__] that's wrongful Joey's
and that's what you're [__] paying
for not some [__] silhouette cracking
[__] written jokes I write unto you
I'm a [__] Savage and he a freak
without warning my appetite for sex
makes me so hot
it's all on me boy and Luna they didn't
get my mother'll timbale Rio Rio your
son Tony Lea
it was Santissima para la gloria papaya
here like wow lunar I happen or you
didn't he who are puta
day that they get them I don't bother
some the lower culo sorry anyway uncle
Joey his draw a little [__] that's
mine yo for the [__] Cubans down in
Miami West Palm Beach I'll be seeing
your [__] in October when ten
days I'll be seeing my boys an Alabama
Huntsville
oh [__] and then we're taking that party
up the [__] Nashville for two
nights
joy what's with the [__] here beatin
smoke there breathe my [__]
lunch break I'm gonna get lost I know I
know
oh [__]
I've been tour or something greensight
you don't make no Leggett [__] stop I
don't remember [__] dick you follow
me but I do remember one thing how to
make it happen on a Monday and how to
make it happen on a Tuesday and how
Thursday Friday Wednesday's month they
do them like [__] Apollonian like that
form the most important thing is that I
get up every morning make it happen
every [__] day tis nothing but
nothing happens on that [__] couch
you don't say
you got a swing dick and give out stop
me get juice every [__] day every day
I don't give a [__] dog till they put me
in the [__] grave that's my my
attitude from now I've been [__]
around enough waiting I'm gonna come up
here with some [__] rap music and
then hey the [__] out here you [__]
[__] you pulled out a gun you didn't
use it right now you're [__] dead who
the [__] is ray uncle Joey always give
it to you straight to write from my
ballsack but most importantly from my
[__] heart as a matter of fact than
cash this weekend Carol Maxwell showed
up I wanna give a shout-out Oh Dan
Lawrence she testified as a character
witness for me August 15 1988 and she
drove for the show this week from
Lawrence and the beautiful thing about
Santa was guess what [__] 30
years playing I didn't let it down
sometimes it takes 30 years sometimes it
takes two years but I'm a [__] just
like the rest of you [__] so it
takes what it takes but inevitably you
always reach your goal look at this look
at this the [__] pink where are you
you think Joey's gonna show up here with
some [__] weed well from some [__]
still not on the [__] corner this
week what do you [__] not so what
let's finish this before you go to the
next line you gotta face you know you
can't eat your pudding if you don't eat
your meat you follow me
take this take the tail off so that stem
doesn't haunt in a weed sack if you
don't compact it on the run always
remember this this these [__] little
periscopes are not about my husband he
ease is about how to economize all the
way see I put this [__] right in
here and we're ready to go
this [__] the lung is [__] on fire
you followed me so I gotta take the
kindergarten I gotta take the
orientation then from there I gotta make
a move then from there they go to
strength training there from there we
got a podcast for you then from there go
to tinker the karate I gotta take a
[__] swim class and that's my
[__] day you understand me some
days I'm a comedian Savage some days I'm
a dad Savage
but every day I'm slinging dick and
that's the most important that's why I
want you guys to understand always be
closing
ABC you know what ABC means something's
gonna suck my dick today that's where
ABC means you're not gonna know that
unless you'd want them put your heart
into it
trust a universe to you if the universe
knows you're committed you're in like
flint but if they know you're not [__]
committed that you're looking for a
handout yeah and you end up in a [__]
Street or [__] they're like a
movement like a mark
don't forget next Thursday Huntsville
celebrity live and then Friday and
Saturday Nashville
I'll see you [__] this
afternoon the Church of what's happening
now I want to give a shout out to all my
weed spots you know I love you I've been
Torah [__] help for greens or
something like that that's in the same
thing as us cryotherapy good people
don't hook you up
tell them uncle Joey sent you and then
you got [__] that's it that's dad I'm
stoned what do you want from me what's
with the [__] questions you know I'm
trying to put it together oh wait you
you're with me and these [__] want to
be with us always forget don't forget
[__] you ain't taking [__] from
nobody today it's your world the rest of
these [__] are just visiting okay
and that's it and that's that I love you
have a [__] great day I'll see you on
the podcast this afternoon the store
Wednesday whatever the [__] it back to
me